[Music]
hello ok alright then I'll just be here
alone seems to be a lot of things and
stuff places for monsters to jump out at
me
no hey okay alrighty then subtle I like
it subtle
I mean I'm waiting for the eventual
extreme scare in my face but subtle good
stuff do you think snakes are actually
gonna bother me or scorpions or whatever
the hell that was
huh I'm a big strong brave boy why is
your doll staring at me that's bad but
everything's fine everything's goddamn
fine everything is hunky-dory you
door-to-door dealer t everything's
hunky-dory in la-la land
hey I'm a kid again back give give Jeff
Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff - Hey - give it to
me
[Music]
oh no no no no nanana nanana nanana
nanana nanana nanana no don't think you
can do that to me
you think you can do that to me you
think you can just do that to me
ha Do You Know Who I am
[Music]
you